we are asked which of these lines are
perpendicular and has to be
perpendicular to one of the other lines
you can't be just perpendicular by
yourself and perpendicular lines just so
you have a visualization for what
perpendicular lines look like two lines
are perpendicular if they intersect at
right angles so if this is one line
right there a perpendicular line will
look like this a perpendicular line will
intersect it but it won't just be any
intersection it will intersect at right
angles it will intersect at right angles
so these two lines are perpendicular now
if two lines are perpendicular if the
slope of this orange line is M so let's
say it's equation is y is equal to M X
plus let's say it's b1 so it's some
y-intercept then the equation of this
yellow line its slope is going to be the
negative inverse of this guy this guy
right here is going to be Y is equal to
negative 1 over M X plus some other
y-intercept or another way to think
about it is if two lines are
perpendicular the product of their
slopes is going to be negative one and
so you could write that there M times
negative 1 over m negative 1 over m
that's going to be these two guys are
going to cancel out that's going to be
equal to negative 1 so let's figure out
the slopes of each of these lines and
figure out if any of them are the
negative inverse of any of the other
ones so line a the slope is pretty easy
to figure out it's already in
slope-intercept form its slope is 3 so
line a has a slope of 3 line B it's in
standard form not too hard to put it in
slope intercept form so let's try to do
it so let's do line B over here
line B we have X plus 3y is equal to
negative 21 let's subtract X from both
sides so that it ends up on the
right-hand side so this we end up with
3y is equal to negative x minus 21 and
now let's divide both sides of this
equation by 3 by 3 and we
get y is equal to negative one-third X
minus seven so this characters slope is
negative 1/3 so here M is equal to
negative 1/3 so we already see they are
the negative inverse of each other you
take the inverse of three it's 1/3 and
then it's the negative of that or you
take the inverse of negative 1/3 it's
negative three and then this is the
negative of that so these two lines are
definitely those two lines are
definitely perpendicular perpendicular
let's see this third line over here so
line see line C is 3 X plus y is equal
to 10 if we subtract 3x from both sides
we get Y is equal to negative 3x plus 10
so our slope in this case is negative 3
so our slope here is equal to negative 3
now this guy is the negative of that guy
this guy's slope is a negative that but
not the negative inverse so it's not
perpendicular and this guy is the
inverse of that guy but not the negative
inverse so this guy is not perpendicular
to either of the other two but line a
and line B are perpendicular to each
other